[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's nick wright first things first
and all-around good guy let me start
with nba news there for you nick
explain gordon haywards uh
philosophy game plan here of where is he
going to end up
well wherever he can get one more
contract would be my guess
i l and i don't blame him for this
obviously what's happened in boston
he's been totally snake bit it started
as terribly as something can start
getting injured in the first half of
your first game he's kind of because of
his level of play since then
been lowered on the rotation as far as
level of importance
and i know people look at gordon hayward
is opting out of 30 million dollars
well yeah but he's probably opting into
what will undoubtedly be
less per year but more total i think
you'll probably get
three years 60 some million dollars
maybe maybe from a team like the hawks
that has money to burn and is trying to
add some veteran leadership i reported
last week i think that
they're targeting rondo to try to help
kind of guide along trae young
so i think that's what happens there and
it's another if you ask me i mean
celtic fans need to understand they
can't replace the asset
they needed him to opt in and then trade
him or do
something they don't have the money to
replace the asset
so boston it's really interesting dan if
boston
you know had the hijack with the nets
the nets are going to tear it up build
it up
tear it down and build it back up before
the celtics make an nba finals
with that heist from them nearly a
decade ago now
has this celtics team under achieved
oh i think so i i don't know if the t
let me rephrase
i think danny ainge is underachieved i
don't know if you saw the latest
you know report a former boston herald
reporter i
apologize i don't have the name in front
of me retweeted yesterday
steve bull bill thank you steve bulpitt
i
you know i assume he used to go on
sportscenter with you back in the day
he he reported that you know they they
had interest in james harden
but then they cooled on it because of
you know tertiary reasons
which makes james harden the 13th
consecutive big name free agent or
or possible player that danny ain't
thought about
but decided this 11 year old in southern
california who he holds the draft rights
to in 2028 is just too good to give up
and so you didn't go and get kawhi the
team that did won the title you didn't
go and get anthony davis the team that
did won the title
and you're not even going to attempt to
get james harden and instead
the nets the sixers the bucks all might
be better than you and that's just in
the east
next year yeah i just wonder what the
game plan is for the celtics because i
do think danny ainge
there's been moments of brilliance there
and you have this young team
i don't know where kemba is i mean i
think kemba uh
feels he certainly looks spent i i love
tatum and i
and jaylen brown but i don't know do you
think they would really consider james
harden in boston
well i think i don't think they will and
it's because
they overvalue their own guys listen
jason tatum is an excellent player an
excellent player
but celtic fans have decided he's going
to win
multiple mvps he'll never win one
and so you don't have a guy that's going
to be a top five guy in the league
you could have had kawhi leonard for
jaylen brown
who is a poor man's version of kawhi
leonard
and you're like no we can't do it and
you can say oh anthony davis wasn't
going to resign
okay you could still try to go win the
title
and you've made one big swing since
you've had all these assets
and it was a swing and a miss it was
kyrie and he couldn't wait he said i'm
gonna
stay there forever and then couldn't
wait to get out of there so i just feel
like
you know boston calls itself title town
the only team that's not holding up its
end of the bargain is the celtics
they've got one ring since the berlin
wall fell
and that's because kevin mchale gift
wrapped him kevin garnett so
i just don't know when they're actually
gonna go for
if you ran the rockets what would you do
uh try to convince them to buy me out so
i can go to a better situation like
daryl did
i mean talk about an all-time move i
mean hey listen you know i think i'm
gonna take some time off but why don't
you give me some money to leave and oh
you're 10 million a year for a way
better situation
listen i empathize with tillman fertitta
a bit
it during the the pandemic if there were
four businesses you didn't want to be
involved in you'd probably say
all right the hotel business the luxury
hotel business that's gonna be tough
casinos that would be tough high-end
restaurants be tough in the nba
how about you own only those four things
and all of those things
so he's in a rough spot i get that but i
don't know what the hell they're doing
i don't understand they they bought a
second round pick for four and a half
million dollars that feels more like
money laundering than team building to
me i don't know what that is but i guess
it's part of the trade they made
for the first round pick so i think
they're gonna have to rip it down but
the problem is
the owner wanted them to get off the
chris paul contract so bad
he i believe i've been told this but i
believe with
you know good reason to believe he was
forced to trade james harden
trades james harden i'm sorry forced to
trade chris paul for russell westbrook
and you give away all those picks so now
you tear it down but you don't have your
own pick so
what i wouldn't do is trade james harden
for a package surrounding 26 year old
cary sliver
if i'm trading james harden i'm getting
ben simmons i'm getting michael porter
jr
i how about this is a fake trade only i
am speculating about
one for one james harden donovan
mitchell
donovan's under contract long term
hardin would you have to get harden over
the fact that he's going to have to live
in salt lake city
but hey james harden living in salt lake
city he might be a 40 point a game guy
with no nightlife donovan and gobert
they're never going to get over it and
they're right now best case fifth best
team in the west but you can't
trade him for carousel burt and spencer
dinwiddie who are 26 and 27 years old in
draft picks that are going to be bad
picks you can't do that
is nick wright from fox sports 1 first
things first
you reported this i think i want to give
you credit for being you know the
journalist that you are
woodward and bernstein when it comes to
james harden's
jersey was retired by a strip club
thank you dan can i tell you something
this is your life you know me i'm a
radio i'm a radio guy at heart yeah
and seven years ago
when i was in houston right after they
acquired james harden
i went and did some investigative
journalism at
dreams made famous by many a drake song
and james ryan's only been there six
months
and what they have at dreams it's a
gorgeous establishment
again i was a younger man at the time
they have
banners of their most famous performers
diamond and there's porsche
cinnamon yeah absolutely
there is one that is not of one of their
performers
it's james harden's jersey and i
couldn't believe it
now pictures are not recommended at
those places but i managed to snap a
small one and talked about it on my
radio show but again i'm doing local
radio i'm dan patrick doesn't even know
my name at this point in time nobody
cares
three years later i think stephen
jackson or matt barnes one of them said
it on cowherd show
and they get all the credit like i broke
the story years ago
so i appreciate you remembering or
knowing that giving me credit for that
uh you've sent out a tweet on taysom
hill you're not all in on taysom hill
starting for the saints i gather
i can't believe it i in fact i don't
believe it
i i sure is he starting sure is he going
to throw the majority of the passes
that's
impossible for new league people think i
don't like taysom hill people actually
for you know this isn't a safe space
people think i don't like white
quarterbacks that's not really true but
i understand why people think it is
i have no problem with taysom hill i
have a problem with the way jason mills
discussed
there are 32 teams in the league that
would love to have taysom hill
he can do a little bit of everything he
is uh
he is definitely worth the roster spot
but
he's 30 years old he's thrown
20 more career passes than me and he's
at
16 million next year i don't he's not a
starting quarterback
now i don't know that jameis is either
but i think jameis there's obviously
more upside jamis is younger
jameis we know has all of the ability
except for not turning the ball over
and we found out he got his eyes fixed
this summer now i don't know if that
means he was color blind but maybe he
just couldn't see the jerseys
maybe lasik surgery jameis winston's
going to be a revelation
i just know tayson hill's not starting
quarterback in this league i know that
we i when the when cam got covered
where the patriots like hey jacoby myers
he could start no just because he played
in high school doesn't mean he gets to
start for the team
uh you should make a bet though if
taysom hill proves you wrong
yeah like what's the bet well you got
you know everybody on your show i mean
i'm surprised you didn't nobody made a
bet with you on taysom hill
well i had here's the thing how about
you wear a jersey
if he has two touchdown passes then
you have taysom hill week
yeah that all you do is say something
nice you wear a jersey it might be a byu
you become mormon
you know i just thought about this i
need to right now
say something nice about steve young by
the way one of the most underrated
quarterbacks in the history of the
league
because i trashed danny ainge and taysom
hill
on this show so there's going to be an
salt lake city
i didn't even think about it the whole
mormon community is going to be against
me you guys are wonderful people
you evidently you don't produce great
quarterbacks in new orleans or great gms
in boston but aside from that i got
you know what for the uh betterment of
your career i'm going to cut you short
now
and just say send you into the weekend
uh
and and i'm rooting for taysom hill now
i wasn't i don't root for anybody but
now i am i want him to light it up
against the falcons
yeah to make me look like an idiot
that's fair can i tell you one quick
thing
just very in these things like this okay
uh
at dinner during quarantine my daughters
get to
they what show we watch we're going to
watch a show my older daughter likes
blackish my younger daughter
the seven-year-old oddly enough is
falling in love with cosby show it
causes big conflict
so my wife and i said you know what if
we're gonna watch them and start
watching family movies
and three days ago we start we stumbled
upon the netflix adam
sandler catalog and i
said to my daughter who's right now
remote learning
i'm going on his jokes i pointed you
down there no
they don't believe me they're like what
do you mean his show i'm like he's a
sports guy no he's not a sports guy he's
an actor
so you have convinced a young generation
of america
with your acting chops that that's what
you do full time so how about that
would you like an eight by ten glossy
that i could make it out to your
daughters you know to the kids maybe
oh yeah that would be great that would
be great just make sure you
sign it the guy from the adam sandler
okay because they don't know your name
okay maybe maybe fritzy can get your
daughter's names and i'll be happy to uh
sign a photo
does your wife want one um
that's that's gonna be a soft note but
i'll
circle back okay thank you nick see you
have a good weekend
that's uh nick wright